I am the greatest video game player on the planet.
Oh this? This is just my bitch from last night.
I don't even know her new name.
Another 'Agar.io' clone.
♪ A seven nation army couldn't hold me back ♪
This is the tale of 'Leet... fuck'?
Oh, you play as a tank in this game. That's cute.
I'll tank all them hoes, if you know what I mean.
So in this game, you shoot blocks, you level up.
It's just like Minecraft.
No one really attacks each other in this game.
Everyone is just a little bitch.
Don't you worry. As soon as I'm leveled up, I'm gonna rek these hoes.
Okay, we got upgrade. What should we go for?
Twins.
That's it baby, keep growing longer.
Oh! Oh, get shit on!
Oh, did you see that shit!?
Did you see that shit, babe?
She's unconscious, but don't worry... she... she consent...
Take this! Yeah!
Get destroyed! Zero deaths!
Wake the fuck up babe, you're missing the fucking gameplay of a lifetime over here.
What is with the Illuminati shit? Fuck off.
Okay we can upgrade. Uh... Triplet.
Take this bitch! Yeah!
(unintelligible)
You got destroyed, bitch.
Oh, you want some? You want some? You wanna play game?
You wanna play game? You wanna play game, bitch?
You wanna play game, bitch? You wanna play game, bitch? Yeah, that's right bitch.
She dead?
Ah, fuck it.
All these fuckin' noobs...
Running away f-
Ooh, Oz!
Welcome to the game, bitch! You dead!
You fuckin' dead.
Oh, Mr. O, how 'bout you suck my hole?
Destroyed!
UUURRNNNGGHHH!!! *TRIGGERED*
Best player in the world!
You wanna fight? You wanna fight me? You wanna fight me?
I'm the strongest motherfucker on this planet.
Have you ever sucked a -
No! I clicked back!
Go back! Go back!
Why do I keep hitting the button?
Bring me back! Bring me back, for fuck sake.
Are you kidding me?
You fucking bitch.
You did this.
Ah, fuck!
God damn it!
God...
♪ Mad world... ♪
I picked the worst fucking class.
I'm not leveling up fast enough. This is bullsh-
Yes, assassin!
(French accent) 'Assassinosh-', assassination.
Oh!
You just got assassinated, bitch!
Oh! Shit!
I'm so good at games!
Oh! More like... "Oh, you dead!". (laughs) [nice meme]
Oh, got 'em!
Fuckin' quick-scope. (pfft) -
If my mother saw me right now, she'd be so proud.
Bitch!
You got fucked.
That was for you mom.
Don't worry about the girl, she is a nice lady
No so close.
No be we are not fucking dying from you
Jesus Christ
Fuck this game
This Game is for fucking pussies, whose fucking spray (nonsense sound)
Zero deaths, that doesn't count.
This doesn't mean shit, you didn't see it, you didn't see anyone.
Zero deaths
I HAVE RETURNED!
I am here to become number one in this game
Let's do it
I am here to become the greatest number one player in the universe
That's it baby. More levels.
Welcome to the real world motherfucker
Hey do I am your friend
BYE BITCH...HAHAHA
He thought I was his friend
Come here Gorgoth!
Goodbye Gorgoth
God dammit
Come on Buddy, come on
Ah you fucking pussy
Goodnight sweet prince...BITCH
You got rekt
Like I rekted your moms ass
OOOO  headshot
OOOH That feels good
BOOM BITCH
Came out of nowhere
Oh we're number 2! What the fuck man
Coming for number one
I told you guys I am the greatest player on this fucking planet
I am catching up to these motherfuckers
I can feel my muscles getting bigger
As I..more I play
I missed, Oh my god I...
NO...NOOO...NO
Wake up...wake up
Wake up...I love
They said
I haven't actually died zero times
Well they were wrong
I have returned
To destroy this game
For once and for all. My bitch is gone.
It's just you and me now
Oh I'm shakin', oh its shakin over here
I am so pissed
That's me baby
We're gonna level up so fucking fast.
You don't even know
Level two...bitch
Give me that bullet damage
Zero deaths
I'm having so much fun
We are going with the sniper
BOOM BITCH!
Came out of no where
Hey buddy, see you in hell punk!
Hey Sony, why don't you make some good games?                           (ง ͠° ͟ل͜ ͡°)ง
Sorry, I lov- I'm a big fan actually..(•_•)
Goodnight sweet prince.
BITCH
Look at this fucker, BITCH
We're top ten. But we are coming for #1
Or we are out
GOT EM!!
(ﾉ◕ヮ◕)ﾉ*:･ﾟ✧
Hey Welcome to the game...BITCH
I think I popped a fucking vein
Jesus Christ, what the fuck is this
What the fuck...what the fuck was that
My haters
Thought I couldn't do it
My bitch
My bitch almost left me
But here I am
On top of the world
Number one
And number two is not even near
I'm the greatest player on this planet--in this UNIVERSE
HEY FEDE, WHY DON'T YOU SUCK MY FEDE
IF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEANA
OHHHHHHHH
We started with Youtube..
and we finished it with
you know what
I dont even care about this game.
I'm so strong
(forcefully) nothing can destroy me!
im too strong
I'm too strong; I'm too powerful
Nothing can defeat me!
Nothing will des--
whatever
whatever. I don't care.
I got my bitch. I'm out
peace out hombres
fuck this. zero deaths.
I don't even give a fuck
I really
Don't even CAAAAAREE!!!!
I DON'T CARE
alright i hope you enjoyed this vid--(fades into weak laughter)
I hope you enjoyed this video
If you did, leave a like! I Appreciate it
Remember to subscribe kids
and as always....
stay awesome bros *brofist* :)
(clip of pewdiepie playing slither.io)